nous sommes prêts à collaborer avec nos
collègues des autres partis pour veiller
à ce que les canadiens aient la loi la
meilleure la plus équitable et la plus
claire pour assurer notre sécurité
collective faire le roseau me quand il
hydrate dire qu'on va appuyer un projet
doit même si on est content que le
principe de ce projet doit parce qu'on a
peur des conservateurs moi j'ai pas peur
est évident mais ce président c'est un
gros bon sens et assuré que toutes nos
forces de police et toutes nos agences
ces qualités ont des pouvoirs de contrer
les menaces de sécurité de terrorisme
cette croissance est la population
canadienne avis oui le canada appuie la
lutte du gouvernement contre le
terrorisme et on connait style le prix
alors que le projet de loi anti
terrorisme du gouvernement un peu le ses
51 fait l'objet de débats aux communes
cette semaine des ex premier ministre et
ex juge de la cour suprême ont pris la
parole pour exhorter le gouvernement à
faire preuve de discernement dans
l'élaboration d'amour comment cette
question dont vous at elle influencé
l'année électorale je retrouve tâche à
michel et danièle bonsoir à vous trois
alors un nouveau sondage qui nous dit
aujourd'hui que 80 2 % des canadiens
appuient le projet de loi c 51
michel c'est très rare là que quatre
canadiens sur cinq cents tentes sur
quelque chose
qu'est ce que ça nous dit alors aussi
très rare écouter on a des résultats
comme ça normalement quand on demande
par exemple rouge en êtes vous pour une
baisse générale des impôts là où il a
d'abord dû 82 pour ça mais ça donne la
mesure de la psychose je pense de
l'intégrisme et du terrorisme qui qui
s'est emparée à des canadiens et des
québécois aussi les sondages le disent
mais on le voit le kart c'est rendu que
des musulmans sont pas capable de
s'ouvrir un lieu de prière une mosquée
dans le parc industriel de shawinigan là
il ya vraiment un problème
mais au-delà de ce 82% mois ce qui le
chiffre qui m'a frappé le plus dans ce
dans ce sondage là c'est le 19 pour sa 2
juin
cinquième seulement 19% qui s'inquiètent
des conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
sur les libertés fondamentales sur la
vie privée
là vraiment il ya un résultat qui à mes
yeux nenê n'est pas très canadien que
sais-je plaisir d'achat mais ça me
surprend pas à cause de toutes les
nouvelles qu'on a concernant le
terrorisme qui continue qui se
multiplient de pays en pays les
attentats qui se fond qui frappe ici à
cause du fait que ça nous ça nous a
frappé aussi à ottawa et à québec
alors c'est quelque chose avec lequel
les canadiens identifie maintenant moi
ce qui m'a frappé le plus la danse c'est
un autre shift 69 % de gens qui pensent
qu'ils devraient avoir plus de
surveillance sur les pouvoirs policiers
de vos pouvoirs qui sont donnés et
l'oeuvre
vraiment je pense que c'est une position
que les conservateurs auraient dû
adopter c'est à dire ce serait un
compromis avec l'opposition avec les
libéraux qui demande ça effectivement
alain pdo pose carrément le projet mais
ça me surprend qui sont qui sont pas
allés plus loin les conservateurs dans
ce sens l'on met à part de ça je pense
que les conservateurs ou un top 10 bons
la population en faveur on fonce on va
voir un très fort débat en faveur de ce
projet oui justement en année électorale
est ce que c'est pas un sondage daniel
qui vient un peu celle et quoi tout le
débat parce que ça risque d'être une
question très importante pendant ces ce
soit ce sort stephen rapp peuvent en
faire une question très importante il a
raison de le faire le sondage
d'aujourd'hui et ce qu'on avait le dit à
radio-canada le démontre clairement il
n'y a aucun doute là dessus ça va ça va
être une question importante à est ce
que est ce que ça va est-ce qu un
contexte mouvant élections un acteur en
octobre prochain sera le domaine parce
que sera changé est ce qu'il y aura eu
de nouveaux actes terroristes qui font
craindre encore davantage des canadiens
la question est assez claire entre entre
les droits et les libertés et la
sécurité qu'est ce que vous préférez un
peu à sa réponse les canadiens sont
prêts à faire bien des sacrifices avaler
bien des couleuvres pour être bien
protégé pour assurer leur sécurité
bon alors les canadiens son sens
assez unanimes sur cette question-là la
classe politique par contre est divisé
on a vu une bd a voté contre ce projet
de loi les libéraux donc qu'ils vont
voter pour mes clients qui voudraient
certains amendements et aujourd'hui
cette sortie de plusieurs ancien premier
ministre et ancien juge de la cour
suprême notamment plusieurs
personnalités dont qu'il met en garde le
gouvernement conservateur est quand même
un appel à la prudence
tasha est ce que ça vient mettre de la
pression sur justin trudeau d'accord
monsieur chrétien et messieurs martin
mais monsieur tron un sort de l'ombre
pour signer ce projet wii écoute ça fait
une brise la ligne on pourrait dire de
dirigeants du parti libéral qui milite
en faveur des droits individuels et qui
disent bon on devrait andré édités avant
de compromettre la liberté personnelle
en faveur de la sécurité et je pense
envoie un message très fort monsieur
trudeau a choisi d'appuyer ce projet de
loi de mon avis c'est une erreur ça
donne toute la place à monsieur mulcair
de le faire et oui c'est vrai c'est
impopulaire ce moment de dire que c'est
populaire de d'appuyer le projet mais ça
veut pas dire que quand les canadiens
regardent le plus proche ce projet là
ils vont pas nécessairement peut-être
changé d'avis et en ayant un grand débat
ça permet d'examiner à plus profond de
façon plus profond ce projet de loi
daniel vous l'interprétez comme ans
rappel à l'ordre j'ai sorti andy peuvent
passer au fond est-ce que c'est pas un
coup de pouce parce que monsieur parce
que ces anciens premiers ministres
défendent pratiquement la même position
que justin ouais sauf que bon il disque
pour je dois les inquiète beaucoup et
qu'il faudra il faudrait des mécanismes
de surveillance et cetera je sais
trudeau dit la même chose mais en vous
de peyssies va voter en faveur du projet
doit alors se montrer crédible
je souhaite redonner ce moment fait de
l'électoralisme il veut gagner la
prochaine élection
il veut pas se faire remettre sur le nez
pendant toute la campagne électorale que
lui il est il est favorable ou jay-z
sous ne se préoccupe pas du terrorisme
il a choisi comme on dit au quai de
jouer façon extrêmement prudente sur la
défensive se retire au peut-être même
impute ce débat en laissant ces veinards
peu étonnant de care s'engueuler là
dessus est-ce que c'est habile
politiquement probablement au niveau des
principes c'est une autre histoire
- justement parlons-en des principes
puisque thomas mulcair lui défend une
position de principe c'est ce qu'il dit
michel est ce que ce n'est pas risqué
quand on voit l'appui de la population
quand même pour ce projet de loi sur le
coup de façon immédiate oui ça arrive
damas risqué mais je pense ça fait
partie d'une stratégie plus globale de
monsieur de monsieur wenger qui veut en
toutes circonstances finalement sur tous
les sujets appareils comme l'alternative
à tous ceux qui ne veulent plus des
conservateurs alors lui il se présente
comme l'homme de principe l'homme ferme
sur ses principes là tandis que monsieur
trudeau ou comme comme monsieur marc
elle le décrit apparaît comme un roseau
un conservateur mou finalement sur des
questions comme comme celle là et on
dira plusieurs diront que bon monsieur
monsieur mode caire représente une
vision romantique un peu attardé du
canada ce pas suffi c'est rare mais je
vous signale quand même que c'est danser
dans la lignée des
et du npd souvenez vous à l'époque des
mesures de guerre la 79ème pdci était
opposé à l'aria ce monsieur mais qu'elle
sera pas comme ça une nouvelle position
d'un chapeau c'est tout à fait
conséquents avec la philosophie de son
parti il choisit il faut dire aussi que
la sortie des droits de douane semaine
dernière celle de reuil romano deux
espèces d'éminence grise du nouveau
parti démocratique a mis beaucoup de
pression sur monsieur manière il était
peut-être tenté lui aussi pour sauver
les meubles au québec de dire ben oui on
va l'approuver ans connaissant années
mais là il ya les pro choix parce qu'à
part ce moment où les traditionnelles tu
vas le payer vous écoutez
d'électoralisme c'est une chose on a des
principes moraux les défendre et vous
allez-vous tenir debout je pense que
thomas mulcair n'a pas eu le choix
weight achats j'allais dire je les
mentionner ses sorties là mais aussi le
fait que si on se rappelle en 1992 le
projet de loi de charles laughton
l'accord de charlottetown qui avait
tellement d'appuis quand c'est sorti et
à la fin de la journée ça a été défait
dans un jeune homme parce que pendant le
débat le plus collection le regarder le
plus qu'il n'aimait pas ce projet alors
il ya toujours le risque on peut faire
aussi mettre la charte québécoise
là-dedans récemment ça n'a pas porté
fruit aux élections alors c'est pas
clair que si à un moment donné la
population est en faveur que dans six
mois dans l'élection ils vont avoir le
même et même un oeil sur le projet alors
on verra
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure les
commentaires est ce que stephen harper a
finalement pas mal d'influx ans sur
monsieur couillard certains ont parlé de
jeu pour le répéter comme il fumait de
harper reed à sion c'est ça que jean
françois lisée disait parce que il veut
muselet à peu ses ministres en tout cas
à l'entrée à l'entrée du conseil des
ministres michel pourquoi cette consigne
maintenant on n'est pas encore à la
harper isation de l'assemblée nationale
je crois pas mais non je pense que c'est
vraiment le résultat ou en tout cas la
sortie de monsieur bolduc qui a fait le
tour du monde c'est quand on dit une
connerie qui fait le tour du monde c'est
gênant quand même pour le chef des
fouilles à nu les gorges chaudes de ça
et il monsieur bolduc
à un moment donné vous savez quand ça se
répète et dans le cadre de ce beau
succès vraiment récidiviste n'ayez pas
le seul on a eu cette semaine par
exemple madame veil qui dit qu'elle
pourrait très bien engagé un intégriste
dans son bureau multiplient les
incidents comme comme cela ça devient la
nouvelle du jour est là le gouvernement
depuis le début de la semaine on le voit
le temps perdu le contrôle du message de
façon très claire et ça fait plusieurs
fois souvenez vous à l'automne de
c'était la mineuse la famille qui est
toujours après jour se contredisaient
des inepties
je pense que de monsieur monsieur
couillard en a assez et s'exhibent
bombay leur voix on va resserrer les
cordeaux mais en même temps daniel les
ministres ne sont ils pas imputable les
journalistes devraient pouvoir leur
poser des questions surtout à un
ministre dont c'est le dossier quand
même
le matin est ce qui devrait pas avoir
été informés sur ce qui ce qui se
passait dans les journaux ce qu'on en
parle à radio et j'ai envie d'être effet
vous au fait qu'il a été informé
peut-être qu'on lui a remis des notes
explicatives peut-être qui les a lus que
tu ne les as pas lui peut-être qu'il ne
les a pas compris je suis pas capable de
vous expliquer comment ça se passe tout
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que les
ministres importants ali ministres qui
sont au sol ont fait d'eux de leur
dossier pense à jacques parizeau
passagers hors délai vague française je
me fais arrêter à 8 heures le matin
j'entends iso est capable de vous parler
d'économie je me fais arrêter aussi j'ai
regardé l'évêque aussi à sa façon avec
au besoin de notes de briefer graminées
sont compétents il est compétent toutes
les heures du jour
au point qu'à 8 heures le matin elle
réveille à la maison aux ae attention
monsieur podium quelqu'un va peut-être
vous poser une question là dessus il
c'est une question de compétence
la solution de monsieur couillard
aujourd'hui ecoutez jean chrétien le
fait la même chose ils sont allés vers
le désastre dit aller chercher gérard
pelletier et dans le lot pour la
remettre son bateau à flot à nos
solutions c'est le remaniement
ministériel mais vous remplacez les
compétents au suco pas de joueurs tâche
a quand même est-ce qu'on peut comparer
ça ce qui se fait à ottawa parce que
monsieur un peu quand même très stricte
avec les journalistes
oui le bureau du cabinet c'est très
strict c'est à dire que tout doit passer
par le centre comme c'est appeler si
c'est une communication écrite ou une
présentation ou quoi que ce soit mais ça
va pas aussi loin dans le sens que si
c'est vraiment ça infantilise je trouve
les ministres de la deûle à dire que
vous pouvez parler pas avant mai ou
après quand vous avez reçu votre lotion
de la journée c'est il aurait dû faire
ça d'une façon moins gauche vraiment
c'est trop évident ce que monsieur
kouyaté parce qu'effectivement ça permet
la comparaison avec ottawa oui les
milieux sociaux sont assez contrôlés
dans dans ce qu'ils disent mais tf1 la
journée écoutes le ministre
le ministre bolduc avait beaucoup
d'autres problèmes c'est peut-être la
goutte qui fait déborder le vase ici
michel qu'est ce que ça révèle quand
même sur les problèmes de communication
parce que monsieur monsieur couillard
quand même ça a pris 48 heures pas avant
que lui-même et il est une trés est
quelque chose de très définitif dans
cette question-là des fouilles à nu
oui bon mais là il ya deux problèmes
différents il ya le problème de
communication moi je vois plutôt je suis
je rejoins daniel un problème de
compétence il vous le voyez jamais
martin coiteux de s'enferrer dans des
explications personnes qu'on frappe qui
se contredisent d'un jour à l'autre
monsieur quoi te connaît son dossier il
pas normal que des gens qui sont à la
tête d'un ministère depuis bientôt un an
ça met les pieds dans les plats jour
après jour c'est après remaniement et
qui a déjà mon sens trop tarder
maintenant pour ce qui est de monsieur
couillard lui c'est un cas un peu
différent et se colle l'illustrent bien
sûr couillard est un esprit cérébrale
c'est un scientifique alors lui arrive
pas je pense à saisir l'émotion qui peut
qui peut s'emparer de la population sur
un sujet comme celui là alors monsieur
couillard a répondu en disant voyons
d'abord les faits et c'est qu'un quand
il fit une fouille à nu comme ça tout le
monde pense à ses propres enfants dont
on veut pas une analyse factuelle et
scientifique on veut savoir de la beauce
du premier ministre quand c'est ce
savoir a été ces affaires là et monsieur
couillard dans plusieurs dossiers c'est
la même chose ce côté je pense par
dossier de l'intégrisme beaucoup de mal
à saisir le sentiment profond de la
population
on pourrait l'appeler type de
personnalité qui est plus de raison que
de fait que c'est monsieur khouya qu'on
devrait amuser et lui remettait en
attendant je blague fumée champeau rien
mais michel raison écouté il n'a que lui
à blâmer aussi parce qu'il ya eu
plusieurs plusieurs virages à 180 degrés
qui menait directement du premier
ministre alors on verra comment les gens
à lison pouvoir continuer à faire leur
travail on verra tout ça avec vous
michel merci beaucoup à vous trois